I think you could say right now it's
it's a two-man race I mean even though
DeSantis is far back he's way ahead of
anybody else you see that between 70 and
80 percent of Republican voters are
picking either Donald Trump who's the
big dog or Rhonda santis who you know
also gets a pretty sizable chunk of
people I think that's because Republican
voters like what they've done while in
office now in this two-man race Trump
has a commanding huge primary lead new
polls published by McLaughlin and CBS
News ugov show that Trump is beating
DeSantis by 36 percent in both now the
former New Hampshire Republican party
chair even noted that the former
president's organizational skills adding
that by comparison the DeSantis people
are rookies now for its part the
DeSantis team rejects that saying the
machine is built full of Rocket Fuel and
ready to launch well as far as the
polling goes they say that their
candidate is the only one who can win a
general and for evidence they're
pointing to a number of battleground
State polls showing that Trump is
struggling versus Biden while DeSantis
wins all the hypothetical matchups so
where do we stand at this point joining
me now is Chris Wilson holster for Never
Back Down a DeSantis aligned Super Pac
and Robert cahali senior strategist and
pollster for the Trafalgar Group which
is not affiliated with any campaign
Chris first round to you are
Battleground polls in this hypothetical
matchup
really enough to go off of right now to
you know Proclaim that you know DeSantis
is the only one who can win this well
that's the case I mean Ron DeSantis
leads to Joe Biden in every single
important Battleground State and in fact
Trump loses again to Joe Biden in all
those States but not just in those
States Laura I mean one of the most
alarming things I've seen recently is
numbers came out of Texas yesterday from
the University of Texas poll that
actually had Trump down to Joe Biden in
the Lone Star State and look if you
can't hold Texas then you probably
shouldn't be the nominee and let's look
at the implications of that the
ramifications of a Joe Biden Victory
which right now not even giving Joe
Biden Texas if you still keep that in
the Trump column if it was a trump Biden
race you would have a Wipeout
intellectual College similar to what
occurred between Barack Obama and Mitt
Romney and I think if that happens and
you're looking at a Democrat taking the
house back Democrats so it's expanding
their lead in the Senate they get rid of
the filibuster they stack the Supreme
Court Washington DC becomes a state it's
just the list goes on and on the
problems that are created by the Donald
Trump by Donald Trump's nominee and
that's why it's so important that Ron
DeSantis is the nominee and I would say
that if you look at the organizations
being put together by Never Back Down
the preparation is there in fact and
when you begin to look at the early
States Iowa New Hampshire South Carolina
Nevada
the DeSantis organization there I think
will be very very strong all right
Robert now you
um were very famous for being the only
pollster to correctly call Trump's win
in 2016. I don't think you got it right
in 2020 but you say that there are some
things that Trump has definitively going
for him in these swing States explain
yeah actually we had the lowest error
rate of any poster in 2020 as well just
a little difference in the final outcome
but no what what we're seeing it's been
it is easy to rely on some of the you
know you got polls that are showing that
Trump can win The Swinging State and
some they're saying that he can't but it
really depends on who's doing the
polling what their incentive is uh
University of Texas they've never
thought the Republicans could win Texas
so I'm not going to fool with that but
there are numerous Republican candidates
who can win this general election and
Donald Trump is most certainly one of
them uh one of the things that people
are really upset about and worried about
these days is with you know Putin and
she and those guys getting together it's
made people very scared more than even
at any point during the Cold War and so
if you ask a simple question
would Russia have invaded Ukraine if
Donald Trump was President every one of
those same swing States majority say no
and then well then you have the most
famous you know Reagan
Robert but but the number one issue
is it not is the economy it's inflation
prices and the economy that's where
Trump has an unbelievable record I mean
2019-2018 versus today to me that's his
strongest argument for winning but to
Chris's point I think what DeSantis is
going to say Tris you can correct me
DeSantis is going to say something like
well Trump's policies were awesome and
we salute Donald Trump but I'm going to
win this thing I'm going to win women
I'm going to win Suburban women I'm
going to win independence and for those
people he's toxic that's what I bet
DeSantis is going to argue so what does
Trump say to move these polls of the
independence and the Suburban women
toward him to combat what I believe
DeSantis is going to argue
well I can't speak to what Trump's going
to do but what I can say is when you
know one of the questions will you ask
is the you know the Reagan test are you
better off now than you were four years
ago
absolutely you know that's another one
of those tests where they then this
economy is the leading indicator and
people say they're better off of the
Trump's economy we've never had two guys
who have both been president in our
lifetime run and have a full comparison
Americans are very good with a B choices
and I know that some of the people with
the scientists and other candidates will
say well Trump has been demonizing and
and we have a better shot well remember
when the Liberals all liked Elon Musk he
speaks up for free speech and all of a
sudden he's a pariah it doesn't matter
who the Republicans nominate they're
going to go after him with the same
vicious Vigor that they have Trump and
so anybody who thinks any of the other
Republican candidates will it'll be a
Panacea and everybody just can't wait
for them to get elected that's not real
oh no the Press is going to Savage any
Republican nominee I think Robert here
absolutely right but Chris one of the
things that the big donors are clearly
concerned about is the you know the the
focus on the cultural issues you know I
love what DeSantis is doing on the
cultural issues but then since the
number one issue for the country and
those independent voters is the economy
do you see DeSantis in a general really
shifting to economic concerns and
perhaps moving away from these other
issues again that people like I you know
I I love this stuff but those people who
are wary of them abortion you know Peter
Thiel one of them said he could support
DeSantis but wants the focus to be on
the economy
sure well hey it's uh look I'm right
there with you in terms of appreciating
what he's done and taking on corporate
capitalism and and making Florida or
what goes to die but I think to look at
some but what someone's going to do in
the future you have to look at what they
did in the past Donald Trump won in 2016
then he ran against Joe Biden in 2020
and he lost what happened with Ron
DeSantis well he won a very close
election in 2018. what happened to the
State of Florida well you saw a massive
change in registration they went from a
deficit of registered Republicans to a
to a surplus of over three hundred
thousand you had people moving in from
Blue States across the country to get
down to Florida where it became the free
state of Florida and what happened with
Ron DeSantis not only did he win an
overwhelming record-setting historical
victory in 2022 but he did so in a
manner that swept Republicans across the
State of Florida into office now I'll
point out Laura he did that in the same
time where we expected a red wave to
occur nationally and it didn't and there
is a study by Jacobson in 2023 that
shows that it's directly attributable to
Donald Trump up where there are races in
which there was not an incumbent
Pennsylvania Georgia Nevada Arizona
Donald Trump's impact on those races
cost us those Senate States and in fact
if you look at another study by Ballard
and others from 2021 in which they
quantify the impact of Donald Trump's
endorsement and record and rate help and
on top on Senate races it cost us 15
seats in 2018. uh 10 in the house and
five well so we certainly I think the
impact of the Trump candidacy it's not
just damaging nationally but it's
damaging down to the state level as well
well they certainly the House and Senate
certainly helped JD Vance in Ohio and
certainly helped I think in New York on
some of those house races we won but
your response to those uh charges Robert
about what Trump does down ballot
well you know it's interesting that he
would say that Trump is not effective
down about and again I'm not here to
defend the Trump campaign I'm here to
suggest that many Republicans have a
shot but in the year when Donald Trump
lost the Republicans picked up a lot of
seats in uh Congress and and didn't have
the impact that everybody would assume
if the loss of presidents they they won
all the way down the ticket so I mean
that's the inverse logic of what
happened last time the fact is we should
have won all those States and the fact
that he couldn't win when Republicans to
the house level were losing I think
shows just what a weak candidate Donald
Trump is well we're going to see this is
going to be fascinating and Chris and
Robert we appreciate the analysis uh
these polls do move and they're all over
the place and this is early so Chris and
Robert thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else